[Music]
46 seconds of transyl logos this is the
exact same logo gag as the first movie
if you're gonna logo us to death anyway
maybe don't be so lazy after a minute of
logos and another 30 seconds of climb
titles we take another 20 seconds
zooming into the castle are we sure this
movie isn't called Hotel Transylvania as
I'm already feeling very sleepy Thunder
crashes in front of a spooky castle
cliche I'm not sure exactly where these
monsters are tracking in all this mud
from but apparently it doesn't even
matter because the carpet is whitest Tim
Tebow's wedding dressing in mere seconds
later also between this in the first
movie it seems like keeping this lobby
clean is a real issue at this point
probably just need to go with laminate
floors and bubble wrap on all the
furniture why would Dracula and Mavis
even be in the pictures if they weren't
going to show up and mine is yeah she's
invisible that's why you can't see her
then why even suggest your friends
should comment on how hot the date is if
they can't see her also as bad and
obvious as that joke and most of the
jokes in this franchise are at least
someone didn't say something about
Griffin's date being from this is the
one from dammit why the hell are the
wolf pups attacking this little girl and
beyond that is matrimonial child mulling
supposed to be funny somehow this creepy
minaj up on the dance floor makes it
clear that these witches believe the old
wives tale about big feet or maybe they
just looked up human monstera you in the
corn let's not get ahead of ourselves
track they've only made unicorn marriage
legal in four countries so far I would
be the bucket of garlic to fly with you
that would kill Dracula so this is an
odd declaration to make to his daughter
just a little harder to catch my breath
since I'm pregnant
odd hold on a movie where was this batty
bump a minute ago when Mavis was in
human form also I have so many questions
about pregnancy based bat human
transformation because the fetus
transformed from a human fetus to a bat
fetus or just a smaller human fetus does
the baby being a hybrid change anything
about its ability to transform what if
the stress of delivery made her
transform while giving birth look maybe
if you don't won't be going there don't
show me a pregnant bat also also cloud
sitting just have some monster bought a
soup so monsters eating other monsters
is apparently a thing everyone's just
okay with occasional monster Bowl ISM
then it was a little dividend little
Dennis is a year old now yes we saw the
candle so no need to double x position
us by saying information that literally
anyone at the party already knows
so our Dracula's crew just at the hotel
all the time I never understood why they
weren't in the first place since the
hotel is supposed to be a safe haven for
monsters but according to the first film
they only came out once or twice
here just in case you were worried that
Adam Sandler had wandered off parade at
all
Alice made us his information still able
to be seen so clearly on a height chart
that was created over a hundred and
eighteen years ago also this movie wants
to be a movie about Drac having a five
year old grandkid but doesn't have the
monster balls to trust the audience to
fill in the blanks so instead we spend
the first fifteen minutes in what
amounts to a life montage that includes
a wedding pregnancy birth and each
birthday of course it might just be
padding its run time to try and hit 90
minutes either way I'm bored AF we just
saw that this kid is already two most
babies get their first teeth around six
months so if I were in the Drac Pack I'd
be less worried about fangs and more
worried that my kid might not ever grow
teeth at all what is that what's the
noise if you taught me it's just the
cell phone I got you why would Johnny
get Dracula the cell phone and slip it
in his clothes what I'm telling you is
everyone bread through sitcom hijinks in
this universe again are we seriously
watching a text conversation happen in
real time sort of this movie could have
been called Hotel Transylvania 2
unfriended yeah got it maybe you should
just get Bluetooth okay Bluetooth come
over here Jesus where did they get these
monsters Catskills if I show you I can
bust a move will you try to fly then
yeah but where's music instant Tunes has
never been a vampire power come on
sweety back to bed back to bed it's
already after 8:00 p.m. don't you
remember the new sleep schedule actually
Mavis you're the one that may need your
memory jog because according to this
board 8 p.m. appears to be the beginning
of free time and one of the only hours
during the day that doesn't involve
sleeping also what's up no more singing
songs before bedtime I'd love to hear
the story behind that actually at this
point I just love to hear any story
other than this one you don't want the
pups to have too much
sugar this was really an issue than why
I have the candy at all did he just
cover me with birdseed is this power
did I miss something about vampires
having the ability to manifest large
piles of birdseed no Gronk movie you're
home
you know how some jokes get funnier the
longer they go on this is not one of
those and he'll be fanging it up in no
time
thank you hanging expositional shrunken
head for not only expositing on us so
thoroughly but also for reminding us
that all this plot nonsense could be
solved by simply waiting a week to find
out at the boy gross fangs or not all he
needs is time with his vampa vampa
vampire grandpa hey their movie will
handle the silly word combinations
around here when you've already got one
person doing it there's no need for a
portmanteau now remember the pad just
keep her distracted and happy but not
too happy capisce
fun fact keep them distracted and happy
but not too happy was also the elevator
pitch for this movie is it shorts
weather we're going I've never seen
Murray wear anything but bandages so how
would swimsuit readiness even be an
issue we can't say nothing about this no
we don't have time for zingers just
plenty of time for running gags that
aren't funny the first time how do you
make in the stupid car seat doesn't
really matter if the car seat itself
isn't hooked to anything the animation
in this film and the first one is great
and there are so many great visual gags
like this too bad the same can't be said
for the story in screenplay and is there
no one that has the ball so just tell
Sandler no every now and then I mean
this is essentially the animated version
of grown-ups - let me just quickly call
home I don't do that okay it's only 1:00
a.m. there Transylvania is 10 hours
ahead of the Pacific Coast time which
means it would be 3 p.m. in California
and the Sun should be out and bright and
Mavis should be charcoal also Drac not
have a plan for Mavis calling because
surely he realized Mavis would call and
check on Dennis the dark father is tough
both yeah Jesus there are a lot of
humans out in the park doing things at
1:00 in the morning I don't
yes not scary but distracting they
really care if Dennis is scary
I thought the main concern was just that
he was more vampire than human I swear
the only reason they brought searching
for blobby squisher here on this road
trip is for the occasional sight gag to
distract us from how unfunny any other
story actually is I haven't done this in
years
we don't need to kill any more we have
pop-tarts
since I'm sitting both of these
monstrosity is this week I happen to
know for a fact that you single-handedly
ate an entire flock of sheep in the last
one so don't play innocent with me
Wolfenstein I'm Wael wolf did you
actually say the word ground are we sure
Wayne actually is a werewolf though
we've never actually seen his human side
despite the fact that he should only be
a human in wolf's clothing once a month
how exactly is wolf Spitzer
simultaneously saying this line holding
the frisbee between his teeth and
growling I see a wolf as well as a
polyphonic ventriloquist this place is
open all night
right sir yes this rainbow teeth joke
makes no sense not only were her teeth
white a split second ago why on earth
would each individual tooth be coated at
different color sandstorm you've ever
seen find they chose to explain
abilities of a character one movie later
after having him do a bunch of the
previous film with no explanation where
are the parents of these kids
I mean it's strange enough that there
are this many of them out skeet parking
at night but not a single one of them
has a conscientious enough parent or
guardian to keep an eye on them bike
park patron conveniently has a helmet
that fits made us that's my girlfriend
suckers your wife Jonny how does anyone
who has been married for almost five
years still make this mistake whoa
oh no no it's maybe let's just take a
few seconds to admire the complete lack
of this movie gives on maintaining the
consistency of taking a vampire's
picture first
Mavis shouldn't even have a profile
picture that would pop up when she's
coming second when Drac answers he
shouldn't show up in the vamp Skype at
all because the camera wouldn't be able
to send any visual of them to each other
third go to hell movie I happy baby
direct wreck somehow sleeps through all
this Howard wrecks fingernails gone do
they only appear when he's trying
unsuccessfully to use a cell phone yeah
we're over here now
had to scale it down insurance we are
vampires
bum-bum-bum bum-bum-bum we have a couple
of mixed families in the neighborhood so
I thought I'd invite them over this
monster is a metaphor for race and
Prejudice idea isn't bad but it comes
out of nowhere disappears just as
quickly and doesn't have the fangs to
really say anything important beyond a
few stereotypically lame jokes what
happened to Michael row your corpse
ashore or old Nick werewolf had an axe
they are horrible jokes that got cut out
of the script you shouldn't be up here
Drac seriously why are you up there it's
one thing if Dracula thinks he has to
take all these drastic measures why
would it require all six of you to climb
to the top we and for the next 30
seconds the movie will make lame jokes
about how the kid is still falling
considering people fall about 500 feet
every six seconds it means he should
have gone about 2,500 feet by now or put
another way the height of two Empire
State building's stacked on top of each
other I mean I know they climb for a bit
but there's no way they could get high
enough for that distance to make sense
we have to call the boy's mother and why
should it be Dennis isn't a member of
the camp they're just visitors the
counselors aren't required to do
anything in regards to him first of all
insensitive much also that's your
daughter you're talking about asshole
what is this movie this was recorded
mere minutes ago and it already has 116
million views
Taytay doesn't even pull that kind of
number in the first full day if Drac is
the one who just smashed his phone why
wouldn't Mavis his phone look this
cracked even if it damaged the glass by
the lens it wouldn't look like this
hotel right now and you better be there
or I swear dad you're gonna be very
sorry
well Mavis has a trip up a little over
6,200 miles ahead of her so if Dracula
doesn't make it back to the hotel before
she does he deserves whatever happens to
him so why can't Dracula just fly back
at the hotel with Dennis like Mavis is
doing with Johnny there's something I
can't unsee not now when did Mavis
become such a killjoy how would a selfie
in any way keep them from getting there
any quicker
this works
I see you've added seeing around
quarters to your zoom and enhance
eyesight cliche fancy sheesh poor vamp
kids 6 6 6 lost over 15 million
subscribers since he posted the first
video seriously how hard is it to put
the tiniest amount of thought into these
details she was killed by angry humans
Phantom of the Opera dick overkill yeah
he'll be at the party I invited him yes
because all great movies introduce an
entirely new character and plotline in
the last 20 minutes of the movie and no
movie you don't get points for dropping
his name once or twice earlier my dad
cannot know you're a human or any of
your family and Mavis was made well
aware that Vlad would not be okay with
her having a human or half human son so
why would she have invited him with all
her husband's human family at the hotel
considering the racial allegory in this
movie and shoehorned in this monster
face act is making me very uncomfortable
you look like you've got the baboon's
butt on your head I'm sure the 1992 Bram
Stoker's Dracula jokes killed with the
kids in 2015 when does this happen I got
a book fair in half an hour where could
he possibly be in half an hour
downtown Transylvania count goes it
Frankenstein actually I'm technically
Frankenstein's monster you've been going
with the Frankenstein moniker for almost
two films now not to mention the whole
Johnny Stein bit in the first one you
don't get to backtrack now a movie then
this might not be a monster yet but he's
definitely not super speed
considering how quickly he ran down the
bridge and up on the hill we don't hate
humans anymore and they don't hate us
although the movies haven't exactly
explained why this is but the story
needs it to be true so all hail
convenient plot and the only boy she
knows none of us do in fact one could
argue this entire chain of events as
made us his fault sure is nice of this
human killing machine to do some monster
monologuing before digging it humans
don't belong with bad stars then explain
gene Simmons Bela explained gene Simmons
[Music]
what a surprise said no one who ever
watched this movie but since Dennis is
clearly a vampire what is Bella's beef
at this point also apparently when you
get your monster power as they come down
loaded straight into you matrix style
with no training needed balls callbacks
are fun but Jesus these movies expect
you to remember a lot I've had to watch
these pretty much back-to-back and I
still had to do some research to make
sure my eyes were dotted correctly and
my fangs were crossed these monsters
seem to have very specific knowledge of
the anatomical abilities of blobby
suddenly appearing bike stuff suddenly
appears also Dennis I'm coming is
exactly what my college girlfriend
screamed at me at the apex of our first
sexual encounter together even though my
name is Nam Dennis why does Dennis keep
his hair as a bat when Mavis and Dracula
keep none of their features daddy you
just saved a human and got over
thousands of years of a deep-seated
belief super-quick this continues to get
sequels
these pipes
[Music]
now this is blind any city that wasn't
flying that was falling with style we
didn't start the fire
[Music]
what dive is he gonna do the crippled
lending I'm Ron Swanson
it comes in 48 flavors we have to try
them all
Tony and topia your mother sucks cocks
in hell